This episode is brought to you by Oculus
rift.
Greetings and welcome to earthlink
cinema.
I am your host.
Garrick's were ameloid.
This week's artifact is avengers
infinity war,
the crossover event that defined a
generation until it was usurped by the
Bridget Jones extended universe.
The film is a squeak wall,
so all your favorites or back Spiderman
for Ilan Musk.
Shrek girl,
Shrek,
cath man,
this guy,
they're all back.
Infinity war follows thin nose rather of
grimace who loves collecting rocks.
He loves them so much.
He straight up murders.
Heimdall and Heimdall is friend.
While Shrek hightails it back to the
swamp,
Aka Earth.
He conveniently lands in.
Doctor Strange is Bachelor Dojo and
tells them winter is coming and it does
in the form of [inaudible] kid brothers,
the avengers protect strange bling and
take the fight to space.
The final frontier for humans in
Scotland.
For some reason,
Wanda and cosmo get hammered
Bush,
but
captain America,
black widow and black man use their
crotty powers to sufficient effect.
Cosmos suggests they cut the stone out
of his head,
so they had to Africa for a little
medical tourism in space.
The galaxy friends assault four in a hit
and run and with all their combined
might they decide to split up.
Half the crew tries to kill fenos but
he's figured out their weakness.
Bubbles,
unlike my weakness,
which is quite eludes,
he kidnaps lady Shrek while four and the
other guys do arts and crafts with
Tyrian,
long esther spiderman and Ilan flash
freeze voldemort and then crash land at
[inaudible] ranch.
Along with these guys,
they concoct a plan to get back
fantasies of admitted while strange has
a math seizure.
Lady Shrek and Shrek Senior Meet Sunburn
Guy who tells him he's got a pawn,
his daughter for some rock over in
Africa.
The other kids unleashed their army,
which they've just decided to use now
back on tighten fenos returns to make
sure he didn't leave the oven on when
he's jumped.
The space x team nearly takes off as
myth,
but quill finds out his g F has been m U
R D murdered.
That's faster.
Their plan goes to crap.
Ilan gets knifed and strange gives up
his chain for realizes he hasn't been
doing anything for half the movie and
day use.
Axe Maki na's into the battle.
Since the Wifi is terrible,
Wanda is forced to pop cosmos it,
but fan knows arrives and rewinds
everything because be kind rewind man
and with all the stones he snaps his
fingers to that queen ditty but have
them bump bump a fat that bottom girls
avengers,
infinity war explores what happens when
power is allowed to grow unchecked like
that thing on your back.
I've been meaning to ask you about Karen
Ou fan.
Osu possesses many marks of power,
obsessed evil kings such as a lazy boy.
How is hated that chair lackeys who talk
weird.
No other beings has ever had them might
ne the nobility wield not one to
infinity stones and a jeweled gauntlet
like the king of Pop.
Mikael Jackson.
He also acts in accordance with the
principle of noblesse oblige the idea
that nobility is duty bound to perform
certain social responsibilities like
genocide.
It's a simple calculus.
This universe is finite.
It's resources finite.
If life has left,
done shirked,
life will cease to exist
and ain't calculus and I should know I
failed it twice.
This approach.
His sentiments from English scholar
Thomas Mouth is are slithering and his
essay on the principles of human
population.
Martha's are believe that population
could be contained through two methods,
proactive checks that increased
mortality rates and preventative checks
that decreased birth rates such as
condoms and birkenstocks,
but like any good movie villain,
Fenos chooses the option that leads to
more toy sales.
Fantas is a played Tony.
He invades plantings.
He takes what he wants.
He wipes out half the population and
doing so.
Thanatos employees,
the old utilitarian argument that moral
choices maximize happiness for the
maximum amount of people.
By this logic murdering half the
population is preferable to the whole
population killing itself.
You were in the bed hungry,
scrounging for scraps.
Your planet was on the brink of
collapse.
I'm the one who stopped that.
You know what's happened since then?
The children born have known nothing but
full bellies and clear skies.
It's a paradise,
although he could make the universe
twice as big.
Screw it.
Ultimately,
the film criticizes both tennis's
unchecked might and his utilitarian
ideals,
but not his weird tunic and boot Combo
is quest for power.
Forces him to choose between ambition
and Familia.
The hardest choices require the
strongest wounds.
While he achieves his goal,
it costs him everything he holds dear.
Namely his daughter who's tried to
murder him on multiple occasions.
Earthlink cinema.
I'm Garrick's where I'm your lawyer and
now a word from my weird intern.
Hey guys,
Gareth's is turn.
Jared here.
My friends are always asking me what
it's like to work for Garrick's.
Well,
it can be tough.
Technically I'm not even allowed to have
friends.
The only thing that gets me through is
Garrick's is awesome collection of
vintage earth artifacts like his oculus
rift from 2018 back then it cost a mere
$399 but as fond of saying at dinner
parties,
it's priceless.
Now,
Garrick's has tons of games too,
including marvel powers,
united vr,
Lone Echo,
brass tactics,
echo arena,
and it seems like he's always getting
more.
Unfortunately,
I'm forbidden to use it.
And Derek's busted me when I thought he
was speaking at an intergalactic
convention of Earth of files.
So now I'm trapped down here in his
basement for what he describes as
eternity.
Oh,
well,
it was worth it.
Check out the link in the video
description to get more info on how to
pick up one of your own.
If you can time travel back to 2018 that
is.